I've been working hard to get promoted but no one's noticed.
What am I doing wrong?
To get to an early start in climbing the corporate ladder,...
...don't guess, go to the source!
Ask your boss what you'd need to do to get ahead.
Ask about what kind of performance is expected,...
...what projects you need to be working on,...
...and what additional expertise you'll need.
Look for ways that you can support what is most important to your boss...
...by tackling the projects your boss least enjoys working on.
To find out if your boss can help you,...
...check his track record for sponsoring and promoting employees.
If your boss talks proudly of his "alumni network" and how often it had provided valuable support to him,...
...then do your best to join his network.
Avoid putting all your eggs in your boss's basket.
Develop a group of people who are invested in your success...
...by serving on projects in other functional areas and with other managers.
Take on the projects that no one else wants to touch. Why?
Because any level of success will get you lots of visibility.
But don't take an assignment with no chance of success.
Get your boss engaged in your success,...
...and you'll walk down the aisle to a more successful career.
But remember not all bosses are prepared to support their people,...
...so you might have to divorce your current one and go looking for a new partner.